on friday jack dorsey and square
announcing that they have intentions to
potentially go into bitcoin mining now
we are going to go through each one of
these tweets because this is a big big
deal square is obviously started in the
hardware business with the dongle that
you used to be able to swipe using your
smartphone but now they have become one
of the largest fintech companies in the
world it's 115 billion dollar market cap
company and we all know that jack dorsey
is very bullish on bitcoin historically
square has done a number of different
things in the industry they one have put
bitcoin on their balance sheet two they
have allowed users of cash app to go
ahead and purchase bitcoin very easily
three is they announced intentions to do
an open source hardware bitcoin wallet
and then four is that at one point they
also have announced that they are
interested in quote an open developer
platform with the sole goal of making it
easy to create non-custodial
permissionless and decentralized
financial services focused on bitcoin so
obviously square is making a very big
play here now around the mining hardware
jack started out and he said square is
considering building a bitcoin mining
system based on custom silicon and open
source for individuals and businesses
worldwide if we do this we'd follow our
hardware wallet model build in the
opening collaboration with the community
first some thoughts and questions he
then goes on to say mining needs to be
more distributed the core job of a miner
is to securely settle transactions
without the need for trusted third
parties this is critical well after the
last bitcoin is mined the more
decentralized this is the more resilient
the bitcoin network becomes true
second mining needs to be more efficient
driving towards clean and efficient
energy use is great for bitcoin's
economics impact and scalability energy
is a system level problem that requires
innovation in silicon software and
integration what are the largest
opportunities here he then goes on with
three silicone design is concentrated
into a few companies this means supply
is likely overly constrained silicon
development is very expensive requires
long-term investment and is best coupled
tightly with software and system design
why aren't more companies doing this
work
four he then says is there isn't enough
focus on vertical integration
considering hardware software
productization and distribution requires
accountability for delivering to an end
customer versus improving a single
technology in the chain does seeing this
as a single system improve accessibility
fifth one mining isn't accessible to
everyone bitcoin mining should be as
easy as plugging a rig into a power
source there isn't enough incentive
today for individuals to overcome the
complexity of running a minor for
themselves what are the biggest barriers
for people running miners and then
lastly our team led by jessie deroche
i'm gonna mess it up we'll start the
deep technical investigation required to
take on this project we'd love your
thoughts ideas concerns and
collaboration should we do it why or why
not we'll update this thread as we make
our decisions and now over to jesse when
i saw this there was two main things
that immediately jumped to mind one
square is building the largest bitcoin
company in the world
it's a 115 billion dollar business today
and we are slowly watching the evolution
from a fintech to a bitcoin company when
you start to look at everything again
from putting it on the balance sheet to
allowing cash app users to buy bitcoin
to creating an open source hardware
wallet to now getting into the
decentralized financial services around
bitcoin and mining you can see that if
jack dorsey pulls this off the 115
billion dollar company would be going
after a multi-trillion dollar
opportunity pretty incredible now these
problems are really really difficult
they require not only systems design
thinking they also require first
principles thinking and they require the
fortitude and the ability to think long
term you can't simply just wake up one
day and say you know what we are going
to get into the silicone chip game
that's a very difficult difficult
business to be in it requires tons of
different skills that square may not
have internally today whether it's the
expertise the experience or frankly the
uh the back
time that they've spent in investing the
capital and the design this is the real
deal now if they would be successful
over the coming years they would
essentially be building a brand new
ecosystem of
products
and services around bitcoin i ultimately
think that building it in open with
collaboration with the community is the
right move i ultimately think open
sourcing as much of it as possible is
the right mood and i think that it is
really interesting to see a company that
has a massive balance sheet that has
that 115 billion dollar market cap doing
this will serve as an example as to why
more publicly traded companies should
start to participate in the ecosystem as
well
one of the ideas that i continue to go
back to is the idea of plugging in to
the bitcoin system what i mean by that
is if you're an investor you can plug
your capital into the bitcoin system
if you are a hardware manufacturer or
you have energy you can plug into the
bitcoin system you can begin mining
if you are a company you can start to do
things in the bitcoin ecosystem you can
plug into the bitcoin network every time
somebody chooses to take an asset that
they have whether it's capital whether
it's services or whether it's something
else and plug into the bitcoin network
they are essentially hiring millions of
people around the world to join their
team whether it is simply by cheering
for their success and saying hey you
believe in the same things i believe in
we're all on team bitcoin we are going
to do our best to help you be successful
or it is something much much more like
using the technology where there's
millions of developers or holders or
people developing various products and
services around the technology you are
hiring the bitcoin community when you
plug into the system one of my favorite
examples is tahini's restaurant in
canada they have nothing to do with
bitcoin but they love bitcoin they
plugged into the system and now people
will go out of their way to come visit
the restaurant they've built a national
brand in the united states and even some
would argue a global brand simply
because they plugged into the system no
one would have thought that a restaurant
could plug into the system but now when
you take that idea and you say square a
hundred plus billion dollar fintech
company plugging into the bitcoin
network it is likely to provide a
massive opportunity that most people are
drastically underestimating so what do
we think about square getting into the
mining business potentially but doing it
from going
uh and recreating silicone and and uh
really producing silicone chips all the
way on up to the actual mining systems
themselves yeah i mean if they're able
to do this on uh like give individuals
the ability to do it for a cheaper and
and kind of on a larger scale i think
it's super impactful right for as much
as uh
you know bitcoin helps with personal uh
economic freedom with decentralization
with kind of all these things this can
democratize the process even more and i
think traditionally when you think of
bitcoin mining you think of these large
facilities that are temperature
controlled and have access to uh you
know cheap power or cheap energy and
they can um that they're using asics
that are tens of thousands if not
hundreds of thousands of dollars and you
don't necessarily think about kind of
the common average person so i think
this gives those people more access and
i think it's a good and important thing
and the one thing i really like about it
is that you know he's open uh similar to
how square has done in the past he's
gonna he's opening committed to doing
this in public
john what do you think yeah dorsey
started recently mining with compass
mining right so he either really liked
the rewards or hated the process that um
was in place and wants to build his own
he's building one of the largest bitcoin
companies uh sorry for the fact that you
can do the whole process now right so
earlier this year he started working on
the bitcoin hardware wallet super
interesting jesse the guy who's running
this team also was heading uh the
bitcoin hardware wallets too and look
payments mining wallets he's getting the
whole ecosystem of bitcoin and bringing
it all together into square uh makes a
lot of sense be interested to see what
he does